around eight years ago I released a
video about the Esperanto language in
Esperanto La temperatures
I studied Esperanto for a couple of
hours a day for about three weeks then I
wrote a script in it then filmed it in
Esperanto two hours a day for three
weeks does that mean I'm a language
learning genius no it means Esperanto is
simple and I wasn't conversationally
fluent of course I just knew enough to
write a script in it and present what I
had written but I guess that's pretty
good for three weeks of casual study but
let's back up for a minute what is
Esperanto many people say it's the
easiest language in the world in fact it
was designed to be just that designed
yes Esperanto is a constructed language
meaning it didn't arise naturally but
was intentionally created it was created
by a man named Dr LL zamenhof who
published the first book about it in
1887. the book was released under the
pen name doctoro Esperanto which means
Dr hopeful one and Esperanto took off as
the name of the language what exactly
was he hopeful about he was hopeful that
this language would help promote
International understanding and
cooperation by transcending language
barriers he intended for Esperanto to
become an international auxiliary
language meaning that it wouldn't
replace anybody's native language but
that everyone could learn it in addition
to their native language and use it to
communicate with people from around the
world at first it quickly started to
gain a following with the first world
Esperanto conference being held in 1905
and the founding of many Esperanto
associations and Publications in 1920
the League of Nations introduced a
proposal to use Esperanto as a language
of diplomacy and almost every delegate
accepted the proposal except for one the
French delegate he used France's veto
power to block the proposal why would he
do that
French was a major language of
international relations at the time but
was starting to decline
so France must have seen the adoption of
Esperanto as a threat to its status and
influence
despite the loss of that major
opportunity the Esperanto movement
continued to make progress but it was
seriously disrupted by the second world
war and the Banning of Esperanto in all
areas occupied by either Nazi Germany or
the Soviet Union Esperanto didn't die
but it seems to me like the war
destroyed much of its momentum after the
war the United Nations chose its six
official languages English French
Spanish Russian Mandarin and Arabic
notice that Esperanto isn't one of them
Esperanto is now highly unlikely to
become a major international language
but its small community of enthusiasts
has gotten a big boost with the rise of
the internet websites like ledenu.net
serve as valuable resources for Learners
and Duolingo also has a course on
Esperanto which is currently being used
by over 300 000 people to put that in
perspective over 30 million people are
currently using the Spanish course on
Duolingo so Esperanto is not going to
take over but it's a language that
brings joy to a global community of fans
every Esperanto
meaning passport service a system for
connecting with other esperantistoi and
meeting them in their home countries and
of course speaking Esperanto together
the internet has been a blessing to
humanity because it makes the world
smaller and brings communities of
like-minded people even closer together
but the internet also has its dangers
and that brings me to the sponsor of
today's video private internet access
every time you log on to the internet
especially if you use public Wi-Fi in
places like cafes airports and hotels
you're transmitting sensitive data that
can be seen by internet service
providers invasive governments and
hackers a VPN like private internet
access hides your IP address and
encrypts your internet connection
protecting your privacy and data would
you leave your smartphone unattended
with the screen unlocked so anyone could
pick it up and look at your
notifications probably not well using
the internet without Pia is kind of like
that you're willfully allowing others to
see your online activity Pia is a VPN
you can trust with a strict no log
policy meaning that even Pia doesn't
have your data so they can't be forced
to share it with anyone else
Pia is also invaluable for unlocking
content on streaming services like
Netflix that's only available in certain
countries
when I was practicing the Indonesian
language for example I used Pia to watch
Indonesian films like sang kiyai or the
clerics in English which isn't available
in my home country with Pia you can
switch between IP addresses in 84
different countries and all 50 US states
with just one subscription you can use
Pia on unlimited devices and if you sign
up using my link in the description
you'll get 83 percent off plus four
months for free that brings it to just
two dollars and three cents a month with
a 30-day money-back guarantee an
incredible deal that you don't want to
miss
many thanks to private internet access
for sponsoring this video now let's get
back to the Esperanto language and talk
about some of its features
Esperanto was designed to be very easy
to learn for as many people as possible
its vocabulary is largely taken from
major European languages especially
Latin and the romance languages Germanic
languages and to a lesser extent Slavic
languages Greek and others zaminhoff
aimed to include words that were the
same or similar in numerous languages
and tried to give the words forms that
would be recognizable and memorable to
as many people as possible for example
there's the Esperanto word pampo which
means field in English there's camp
which now has a more specific meaning
than field but it's pretty easy to
associate the meaning of field with
account in German there's conf which now
means fight but from the meaning of
Battlefield in French there's Sean in
Italian Spanish and Portuguese there's
Campo or kampu and in Greek there's
kambos which refers to a plan and so on
so for speakers of any of those
languages the meaning of the word is
either obvious or there's a clear
connection that makes the word easy to
remember let's see that word in a
sentence
they're working in the field word for
word they work in the field ili the word
for they is similar to Latin ili which
means they or those and to its
descendants in French Spanish Portuguese
Etc it seems that Esperanto has a
tendency to prefer romance vocabulary
when there's no word that's used across
multiple families
next is laboras the root word is labor
this resembles the word for work in
Latin and Italian and the verb meaning
specifically to plow or cultivate in
other words to work the land in
Portuguese Spanish and French and of
course in English we have the word labor
meaning work both as a noun and as a
verb n is like n in Spanish but also
resembles the word for in and multiple
romance languages as well as in Germanic
languages including English of course La
is the definite article like the in
English it resembles one form of the
definite article in Spanish Italian and
French note that Esperanto doesn't have
an indefinite article like ah in English
so this sentence is very heavily romance
based but Esperanto also has a lot of
words from Germanic languages and others
you might be thinking aren't those All
European languages how is Esperanto
supposed to be an international language
when it's completely based on European
languages yeah that's one of the main
criticisms of Esperanto it's eurocentric
features but even if its vocabulary is
less familiar to people in many
non-european cultures it's still quite
an easy language to learn because of its
very simple features what makes it so
simple well all grammatical structures
and rules are regularized with basically
no exceptions nouns singular nouns end
in o after the root word Domo house
Libro book toggle de plural nouns are
formed by adding J pronounced
houses libroy books tagoy days nouns
have two cases nominative with no
special case ending and accusative
usually for the direct object object
which has the case ending n domon domon
libron tagon
La Libro esta Sur La Table the book is
on the table
I'm reading a book note that the stress
in Words with multiple syllables always
falls on the penultimate syllable in
other words the second to last syllable
Libro estas Tablo Legas libron
adjectives singular adjectives always
end in ah Grandad a big house Bona Libro
a good book plural adjectives end in j
like nouns
big houses bonai libroy good books in
the accusative case they end in N just
like knelt she posed
she owns two big houses
remember that the O suffix on nouns and
the ah suffix on adjectives are attached
to the root word so you can easily spot
related words like amiko meaning friend
and Amica meaning friendly Bono meaning
goodness and Bona meaning good because
the suffixes are completely predictable
you can easily guess how to say words
you've never heard before if you know
the root
adverbs adverbs are formed by replacing
ah with e Amica friendly becomes amike
in a friendly manner Li Parolees amike
he spoke in a friendly manner Bona good
becomes bone well midorumis bone I slept
well
verbs verbs are not conjugated for
person or number be comprenas I
understand the comprenas you understand
both singular and plural Lee comprenas
he understands
she understands
it understands G is used for objects or
animals
we understand
they understand the verb is the same in
each of these sentences this is the root
word and us is the present tense verb
suffix
there are a few different tenses and
moods in Esperanto and each one has its
own suffix
to form the past tense you use the
suffix is
he didn't understand word for word he no
understood note the simple way of
negating sentences you normally just use
the word
I didn't like the film word for word
it's I know liked the film accusative
form
to form the future tense you use the
suffix
osas
I think that they'll understand word for
word I think that they will understand
I hope that they'll like the film word
for word I hope that they will like the
film accusative form you've probably
noticed already that the syntax often
mirrors the English syntax quite closely
but with some simplifications
note the conjunction K that's used to
introduce a subordinate clause with
additional information like that in
English it's based on the word K in
Italian and K in French Spanish and
Portuguese
to form the conditional mood you use the
suffix
I would go if I had more time word for
word I would go if I would have more of
time notice that the conditional form is
used in both verbs here unlike in
English
as a side note notice the way to say
more of something
more time literally more of time
more money literally more of money the
preposition da means of specifically for
quantities for other uses of of the
preposition de is used
to form the imperative you use the
suffix ooh
give me my money word for word give to
me my accusative form money accusative
form to form the infinitive you use the
suffix
to hope
he doesn't want to work today word for
word he no want to work today
you may have noticed that the personal
pronouns more or less resemble the
subject pronouns in various romance
languages though me resembles an object
pronoun when they're used as object
pronouns you simply add the accusative
ending in
he likes her and she likes him
indirect objects are expressed using a
preposition
I gave him the key word for word I gave
to he the key accusative in this word
for word translation I'm using the word
he to show that the pronoun is the same
as the nominative pronoun
possessive pronouns and possessive
adjectives are formed by adding the
adjective suffix ah to the pronoun me
becomes Mia Mia frato my brother via
fratino your sister Leah patro his
father Shia patrino her mother Nia filo
our son Ilya filino their daughter
and if this noun phrase is accusative it
takes the N suffix shiamas Shian
patrinon she loves her mother notice how
feminine nouns can be derived from
masculine nouns with the suffix in which
is Then followed by the noun suffix o
this is only for natural gender of
humans and animals
but Esperanto has no grammatical gender
a word like tasso meaning cup has no
gender
now let's look at some greetings and
other basic phrases in Esperanto saluton
this is the typical Esperanto greeting
like hello it might remind you of French
Spanish saludo Italian saluto or English
salutations notice that it's a noun in
the accusative form why well it
literally means greeting and it's like
saying I'm giving you a greeting the
greeting is the object of an action
how are you doing word for word how you
fare the verb here is the present tense
form of to fair or to be doing in other
words to be in a certain condition don't
confuse this verb with the verb Fadi
which means to do in its usual sense
I'm doing well remember that bone is the
adverb meaning well and Bona is the
adjective meaning good
thanks the root word here is dunk which
is like thank in English or Danka in
German and similar words in other
Germanic languages
it's a singular noun and like saluton
it's in the accusative case why because
it's like saying I give you my thanks
the following greetings are also in the
accusative
good morning mateno resembles the word
for morning in French and Italian matina
bonan tagon good day again we see the
word tago which resembles the word for
day in German talk Dutch Swedish dog and
so on
vesperon good evening vaspero doesn't
resemble many words I'm familiar with
but it does resemble the word for
evening in Catalan vespre
do you speak French word for word
question marker you speak the French
notice that the letter c is pronounced
in Esperanto but when it has the
diacritic above it it's pronounced cha
to form a yes or no question in
Esperanto you add the question marker
Chu to the beginning of the sentence the
names of most languages are preceded by
the definite article LA but not
Esperanto
do you speak Esperanto yes nay
on vivolas what do you want word for
word what accusative form you want
Keo is the question word meaning what
and here it's in the accusative form
volas is the present tense of Voli and
resembles the French verb meaning want
the Italian verb volere and German volun
which is related to English will
mishatu's Classon darujavino I'd like a
glass of red wine word for word I would
like glass of red wine notice that the
verb chatus is in the conditional form
where's the train station word for word
where is the train station
is the question word meaning where estas
is the present tense of esti the verb
meaning to be the word for train station
statsidomo is a compound word of estacio
meaning station and Domo meaning house
I feel happy today word for word I feel
myself happy today
centas is the present tense form of the
verb Senti meaning to feel it resembles
the verb meaning to feel and numerous
romance languages it's followed by mean
the accusative form of the first person
singular pronoun but here it's used as a
reflexive pronoun to show that you're
feeling something within yourself
Felicia is the word for happy which
again resembles the word for happy in a
number of romance languages
I don't know an Esperanto how do you say
I don't know in Esperanto word for word
how one says I don't know in Esperanto
Oni is an impersonal pronoun like one in
English that refers to people in general
didas is the present tense of Didi which
means say onidiras
you say ministias with the word one says
I know no
is the present tense form of the verb SI
meaning to know it comes from the Latin
verb meaning to no and the English word
science also comes from a related Latin
noun
let's take a closer look at the name of
the language Esperanto the root of the
verb is esper which means hope similar
to the verb for Hope in Romance
languages like French Spanish and
Portuguese the O suffix tells us that
this is a noun then there's the other
suffix ant after the root this is a
present active participle suffix which
gives the word an adjectival meaning
here's something like hoping but it
needs an additional suffix to tell us
what part of speech it is ah to make it
an adjective e to make it an adverb or o
to make it a noun Esperanto is
an adjective
esperanta I'm hopeful
esperante is an adverb minors
I'm just sitting here hoping someone
helps me word for word I only sit here
hoping that someone will help me
accusative here esperante is an adverb
because this whole Clause is describing
more about the action of sitting
these three words are all based on the
present active participle there are also
past active participles with the suffix
int and future active participles with
the suffix aunt
for intransitive verbs like aspari these
are all the forms but for transitive
verbs there are also present past and
future passive participles too La Domo
estas construata the house is being
built the verb SD indicates the time and
the passive participle indicates whether
the action is in progress complete or
about to be done in this sentence it's
in progress
La Domo estas construita the house is
built here estas is still in the present
tense but this is the past passive
participle so the action is complete La
Domo estas constrota the house is about
to be built this is the future past
participle but the verb SD could be in
the past La Domo Estes construata the
house was being built La Domo Estes
construita the house was built meaning
it was already complete La Domo Estes
constrota the house was about to be
built and the verbesti could also be in
the future but I'll skip that for now in
my opinion these participles are the one
thing that stands out as a little
difficult in Esperanto when you first
discover them it's like wait I've been
tricked they said this would be easy
well the participles require effort and
practice but the verbal system of
Esperanto is still quite simple compared
to most natural languages
don't crocodile or you will face dire
consequences word for word no crocodile
imperative form or you will face
terrible consequences crocodile what do
you mean by crocodile crocodile is a
verb used by Esperanto speakers to refer
to the use of other languages in an
Esperanto speaking context for example
if you join an Esperanto Meetup but you
walk around speaking English or even
worse French then the other attendees
might just snap Esperanto speakers
believe in global Harmony peace and
tolerance unless you crocodile then you
better run for your life
no secret that I've trolled the
Esperanto Community numerous times
throughout the history of this channel
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the Lang
Focus Channel this is a quick video to
bring you some breaking news from the
linguistic world according to recently
released documents the European Union
will soon be adopting Esperanto as an
official language
but the truth is I think Esperanto is
pretty cool
start to learn a new language there's a
feeling of excitement and Elation that
comes with the initial stages of Rapid
learning but that feeling Fades as your
learning slows but with Esperanto that
feeling doesn't really fade because
without any complicated structures or
exceptions you maintain a rapid pace of
learning it's a lot of fun the only
problem is that it's not widely used
outside of the small Esperanto community
so I don't practice Esperanto very often
I would also say that learning Esperanto
doesn't give you the experience of
unlocking the door to an authentic
culture that you can fall in love with
there's a community and a movement but I
wouldn't say it's a culture so to me it
doesn't feel like as deep of an
experience as learning a natural
language but since it's an auxiliary
language maybe that's the point it
doesn't belong to any culture or country
if you know some Esperanto what's been
your experience in learning it and to
other people what's your impression of
Esperanto
and as always a special Thanks goes out
to all of the langfocused patreon
supporters especially the ones whose
names appear on the screen they're the
top tier patreon supporters so many
extra special thanks go out to them if
you're interested in constructed
languages like Esperanto check out this
video on tokipona I made a few years ago
it's totally different from Esperanto
but equally interesting